Speaker 1: What is going on in
Florida right now with coronavirus
is so hellacious. It's so dreadful. It's so
vicious that if we're not careful, Republicans
might make Ron DeSantis there. Twenty twenty
four Republican presidential nominee, Republicans
seemingly obsessed with choosing the worst people
to be their nominees. And DeSantis is really
messing things up in Florida. Let's take a look at
what's happening. Florida started the pandemic not
well. Rhonda Santurce very early saying closure
is now open. Everything WWE needs a place for
wrestling matches come to Florida. UFC wants to do
fights, come to Florida, bring the cruise ships,
ban masks, ban masks and school on and on and
on. OK, first of all, the case Grauwe in Florida
almost looks like a cartoon since the end of
July. Florida, which is just one of fifty states,
it represents just six percent of the country's
population. Florida regularly hitting twenty
thousand cases a day. Twenty five thousand cases
a day, day after day after day. Even these numbers
may be low because of lack of testing. I got a
report yesterday from a viewer in Florida who
said at doctor's offices there can be a five hour
wait to get a covid test. And then the only other
types of testing you can get are the ones that
you have to book days in advance. And then you
often don't get the results for days either.
So it appears as though, at least anecdotally,
the testing of the testing availability in Florida
is so dire that the case counts are probably
being undercounted. It's it's so terrible
in Florida to get a test that many people
who should be getting tested just aren't. And we
are getting an undercount by every every sense of
the data on on the ground. Now, you might come in
and you might say, well, hold on. But but but but
if the vaccine makes covid not serious, then
cases don't really matter since people who are
vaccinated and gets covid don't really get sick.
Right. Well, this is a Florida explosion, mostly
of the unvaccinated. As we're seeing in many
states. Florida's covid hospitalizations have hit
another record high. Now, you might say, David,
right before you went on break, didn't you tell us
Florida's hospitalizations hit a record high? And
I did. But it's a new record. We've surpassed that
number. Covid hospitalizations hit new high
in Florida. A new report from the Florida
Hospital Association showed sixteen thousand five
hundred twenty one people hospitalized with the
coronavirus, up seven seventy three from the day
before and one hundred sixty two percent higher
than this time last year. Now, then,
you might say, OK, hospitalizations,
but we're better at treating it now. What
about deaths? Florida has done something,
I guess we can call it slick. It's really
completely dishonest about death reporting,
as you can see here. As all of this ramped
up in Florida, death started to skyrocket,
but when you look at the death count, if
you look at the chart we have on screen
a few days ago, all of a sudden the deaths dropped
to almost zero. How how did they do it? Oh,
my God. Run to Santa Suffixed covid. There's only
there's almost no deaths in Florida anymore. How
do they do? Record cases, record hospitalizations
and the deaths dropped to almost zero. Well, they
are lying. And what I mean by that is they are
being very deceptive in how they report deaths.
They are reporting deaths in bulk infrequently and
on a delay. So when you look at the latest days
always seem low. It looks like there's been this
big decline. If you look at our chart after a
bunch of days with one hundred deaths a day, one
hundred and ten deaths a day and 20 deaths a day,
suddenly Flora Florida had 11 deaths on Monday,
only seven seven deaths yesterday. How could this
be? The answer is these are not real numbers. In
another week, they will come out and report the
death numbers. For this week, they will be high,
the chart will be readjusted. But then again,
there will be blanks. It'll be almost zero for
the dates next week that are recent. And it always
looks like it's a huge decline. It's incredibly
deceptive because at any point a denier,
someone who doesn't understand what Florida
is doing with the death numbers, they can
just pull up the data and say, look, massive
decline in deaths in Florida. It's completely
deceptive. Florida is on covid fire. More than
five thousand students are now quarantined or
isolated in just one school district. We're
seeing pediatric ICU cases in Florida like
we haven't seen anywhere, the entire pandemic.
And this is after a very short period of time
of schools reopening. Many of the pediatric ICU
cases may not even have been from any school
contagion yet. So it could get even worse in
Florida, if you can imagine. And we're going
to have more coverage of the Florida situation on
The David Pakman Show Instagram. Make sure you're
following us at David Pakman show. If you want
to know what I was up to for the last 10 days,
follow my Instagram at David Pakman. And we have a
very if you want a vegetable break. I had a crazy
backyard garden harvest waiting for me. When I got
back from my trip yesterday, I posted a picture
to my Instagram at David Pakman. Find it.
Follow me and we'll be back right after this.